there is a very logical case that you
can make that Iran even if it had a
functioning nuclear weapon and it's
still months if not years away from that
there's a very logical argument for them
not using it this is a regime that yes
is deeply ideological has been deeply
ideological since 1979 but even more
than that has shown itself focused on
self-preservation it's not a regime that
is suicidal it's a regime that in the
1980s drank what the then supreme leader
called the poison chalice and agreed to
end the war with Iraq it's a regime that
is always place that survival above
everything else to build and then use a
nuclear weapon would be a suicidal act
for the regime because it would invite a
response in kind from Israel from
Western powers and so I think the the
assessment that many people have
including a good number of people here
in Israel is that Iran wants a weapon
not because it plans to use it
imminently but because it wants a
nuclear deterrent